foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio live in
Nashville Tennessee it's the Ramsey show
where we help people build wealth do
work they love and create actual
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
Jade warshaw we're taking your calls on
money life mental health relationships
work whatever you got going on we've
probably got an opinion on it and if we
can't figure it out we'll just tell you
we don't know what we're talking about
um the call is toll-free and that's
about what the advice is worth triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go out to Logan in SLC what is up
Logan in Utah what's up man
hey thank you for taking the time to
discuss my question today you got it
thanks for calling in what's up man
yeah so um I'm about to graduate from
graduate school my wife and I have two
little boys and we're looking into home
buying options
um I just accepted a job a full-time job
down just south of Salt Lake City
um the housing market in Utah is very
booming right now
um so we're looking into the options for
renting versus buying we would like to
buy a home we like the idea of following
the principle of keeping a mortgage
payments about 25 percent of our monthly
take-home pay but this doesn't leave us
with a ton of options
for home buying
um so we're just kind of trying to to
see if it's more worth it for us to get
the foot let's get our foot in the door
and buy a home that may stretch us a
little bit or if it makes more sense for
us to rent and try to build up a bigger
down payment but with rent prices the
way they are in the area we're just a
little bit concerned that by the time we
pay our rents and try to save up for a
down payment we're going to be gonna
cost us more than if we were just paying
a mortgage payment anyway so interesting
get your thoughts on it what are you
graduating with what's your degree in
it's a master's in landscape
architecture outstanding and I'd say hey
I got a buddy out that program that's a
fantastic program
well done dude
um thank you so I've got a a non-money
related opinion on this and then I'll
pass it over to Jade who can break down
the the baby steps for you
I would not buy a house
moving from Salt Lake to are you like St
George areas that we're going
no so right now we're up in Logan at
Utah State University and then we're
looking to move to Utah County Provo
Lehigh area okay just uh 30 minutes
south of Salt Lake so the reason I
wouldn't do it is
I would rather go with my young family
and get settled in that community
and figure out where the cool
restaurants are and where the walking
trails are and where the parks are all
that stuff that makes for a great life
and not have tied myself up in to a
house and then tried to do life around
where we stuck a flag and I know that's
such a pain with two little ones to move
twice the thought of moving twice was
enough to make my wife just start
weeping instantly right and so I get
that
um but man
the times I have chosen to rent that's
that's just a Delaney family rule we
rent when we move to a new town and we
get settled
um we even rented when we moved back
into a city we had lived in for years
because the city had shifted a little
bit so that's just my thought on that
what do you think I think that's a
really great place to start that's kind
of a Ramsay Principle as well is we we
would tell folks you know if you're
moving to a new area wait a year and
just like you said find out the area see
if you like it I do have a couple of
questions financially I'm it sounds like
you guys do the baby steps and
understand I just want to double check
no debt right
um so the only debt that we have right
now is a small student loan but that's
kind of up in the air as far as when
those payments are going to need to take
place or if those payments leave right
now how much is right now
it's 16 16 000. we've been making
payments um while in grad school and
whittling that down okay do you have any
money saved any liquid cash we do how
much yes we do about um eighteen
thousand uh hold on hold on hold on hold
on if you're dead do you love the are
they are they do they keep you warm
Logan do you love them the 18K is what's
keeping him warm the 18K is his buddy
his cuddle buddy all right so here's
what you need to do here let's just walk
through the baby steps because at first
you're gonna be like oh no and then
you're gonna be like oh yeah okay so the
good news is you have the money to do
everything you need to do to get the
right foundation so let's walk that
through the baby steps we would say get
a thousand dollars saved as your starter
emergency fund keyword starter so that's
one thousand dollars that leaves you
with 17 left and then we would say pay
off all of your debt except the house so
you can knock out all sixteen thousand
of those student loans which now is a
great time to knock them out because
they're on pause they're on freeze you
know they're not collecting any interest
so now's a good time to knock them out
and then you can still have another
thousand saved up so now you've got 2
000 going towards you're now three to
six month emergency fund so does that
give you hemorrhoids to just even think
that way that's all you have in the bank
no it's all right that's good okay so
why haven't you done it he didn't know
John yes he did Logan you know did you
know Logan
yes yes I did well I mean there's
with the the potential loan forgiveness
we've made Paws taking a pause on our
payments just in case that goes keyword
potential you've got plan you've got
plans you're we're not going to wait on
the government to do all the things that
we want to do with our life and family
so go that's I mean that's honestly
where I'm coming from so we don't know
what the government's going to do these
Jokers take forever so let's not wait on
them let's go ahead and do this and
here's the thing if it goes through go
if you feel like you need to get you a
refund get you a refund but none of that
is even real yet so let's deal in the
realities of what's actually happening
so yeah I would do that you'd have the
two thousand dollars
um as kind of a jump start to get three
to six months saved and then
now we're starting to work towards a
home purchase so we want to go to baby
step 3B which is saving for a down
payment now the good news is this is
going to move really quickly for you so
during this time like John said you guys
get to know the area start doing some
math we've got a really great calculator
um on Ramsay Solutions it's called how
much if you Google how much home can I
afford and you'll find that calculator
and so you can start to work towards
what that's going to look like but I
would rent until you can put a
responsible down payment on a home that
you are interested in I would say no no
less than 10 percent
um so that you can make sure that you're
building up some Equity fairly quickly
how does that sound to you
yeah yeah no I mean that sounds great
mostly yeah we've just been kind of
trying to weigh weigh the options and
see what's going to make the most sense
for us and I feel like everybody has a
different opinion so it's good but you
like ourselves but you like ours the
best well we're right of course hey
Logan can you and I have a quick just to
the side private conversation
sure there may be a couple million
people listening I'll go over to the
side hey here's the thing
um what's your job right now
um so I currently work part-time in the
job that I will have full time okay good
gig what's your salary gonna be yes it
is it's gonna be eighty thousand
outstanding excellent well done out of
out of grad school and with the
landscape architecture you're going to
end up moving up in that company and you
know that you're gonna you're gonna do
great
this is just two guys
uh having nachos
you got a great job and you took out a
loan and nobody tricked you nobody
pulled one over on you you told whoever
gave you that loan whether it was the
school or the government whoever hey
I'll pay you back you help me get
through school I'll pay you back
I'm all for loan forgiveness for people
who got taken advantage of and ripped
off for those of us who had great jobs
who have been blessed with good work I
think it's on us to do what we said we
were going to do when we signed that
piece of paper and not wait on the
government not wait on your neighbors to
pay off your loans but you pay them off
do the right thing man pay them off and
be debt free by the end of this
afternoon and then head on
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by Jade warshaw triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five taking your calls on money life
marriage mental health work whatever's
going on let's go to Michaela in
Colorado Springs what's up Michaela
hi thanks for taking my call um who
um
about about
eight thousand dollars worth of debt
which is awesome yeah
um
we recently found out that we're
expecting our second baby wow yeah yeah
it's awesome but I haven't told the rest
of my family yet like so are we the
first ones only you guys Jordan and my
parents and I are like the only ones
this is quite the announcement
I'm head of your family yeah well I'm
not like my parents know and his parents
anyway
um so we're we're on baby step two and
we need a bigger car to hold like two
car seats because we have a little
toddler right now
um and I was wondering how in the world
do you save up for a car while uh doing
the debt snowball okay
um couple questions do you mind if I ask
you a couple of questions Michaela sure
okay thing one well let me let me let me
do the good news first so you don't
you're not mad at me number one yeah if
you're have a baby on the way we would
say to just pause the baby steps in
general and stack up money for a baby uh
whether that's stacking up your
deductible or just getting ready for you
know the I mean you're bringing a new
human in the world there's so many
variables there so we would say to to go
ahead and pause that we call that stork
mode so you could do that
um as far as the car is concerned that's
where my question came because you said
you had two kids and most of the cars
that I've seen on the road you can fit
two car seats in the back I'm calling
shenanigans Michaela what kind of car do
you want
um uh I I prefer a Subaru Forester of
course
it was very specific
how about say this the official core of
Colorado of course what do you drive
right now
um a Subaru Legacy so it's really low to
the ground and I don't feel very safe
having my toddler in there okay I know
so I I'll speak for me jade we did
um
my son who's humongous and my daughter
and my wife in a used Prius
2010. come on for a long time and there
was lots of legs and elbows and arms and
there was no car payment so I'm with you
on the safety thing I always had this
this like man I'd feel safer if they
were in a like in a Hummer or a suburban
and I felt even more safe not owing
anybody any money with two little kids
booyah that's just my thought what did
you see all the same boat my thing is
this you bought the car was safe three
months ago yeah and then once baby comes
suddenly it's not safe I do think that
what John is saying and what you're
saying I think there's some validity to
those feelings but at the end of the day
I feel like it's really more based on
feelings
um how much debt do you have overall
about
sorry I calculated it earlier but I
forgot oh 31 000 31 000. okay now this
Subaru that you have now has it given
you any like it is is it just it's low
to the ground I feel like I just want
something bigger or has it given you
reason to say hey this is not a reliable
car whatsoever
um well it is well to the ground and
I've had like two car seats in there
before whenever I've gone with a friend
somewhere but it was very squished and
not very comfortable for either one of
the little little babies and things but
they're in their car seat they don't
know
they don't know they're in their car
seat I think here's I think like the
passenger wasn't very comfortable either
well they'll be all right they'll be all
right to me right yeah I I really want
to challenge you on this
um Michaela I want to challenge you big
time to not buy a new car right now
you've got debt I want you to clean up
your debt I want you to go on stork mode
pause stack up as much cash as you can
for this baby once this baby is born and
is healthy and everything is good to go
um then take all that money throw it
towards your debt snowball and then
after that if you're feeling like you
know what before we you know go much
further I want to save it for a car you
could do that but other than that I'm
not I'm not buying it John no I here's
the thing I had a picture of
what my life would be like I didn't even
know that picture was there yeah when I
had two kids and what my house was going
to look like what my cars were going to
look like and it took some adjustment it
even took some grieving on my part
because the house I had in reality was
much smaller yeah and the cars that I
had were much less nice and everything
was great I think that I think these
major Milestones I got a new job I got a
promotion and a raise I'm having a kid
if you can hold steady in those big
moments and not let your lifestyle swell
up to accommodate what the world's
telling you you got to do yeah that's
those are those magic little moments
when you you get ahead absolutely
absolutely the case yeah I I mean what
she's saying I think we've all felt that
but I did with all my heart I get it man
I hurt for it man but I just can't just
don't know don't do it don't do it all
right today's question comes from
Tiffany from Michigan
Tiffany writes I love this my husband
fully believes in you
[Laughter]
I do not I have serious doubts when you
don't have the income to take care of
your debts how does your 100 month in
savings become over a million dollars in
30 years I mean seriously we have five
kids all the way down to 10 month old
twins we are dealing with formula
shortages job shortages and an insane
increase of cost of living
how can you possibly possibly believe
what you preach is easy when the economy
has changed okay okay there's a lot here
okay Tiffany I'm gonna I'm gonna track
with you on this uh yeah it's not easy
that's the first thing I'm gonna say
nothing that we teach is easy and I'm
saying that coming from someone who
started this journey with a thirty
thousand dollar combined income with my
husband and almost half a million
dollars of debt there is no piece of
that that is easy there's no piece of
that that is fun it is a is a slog man
it's it's a struggle uh struggle slices
if you will and um but that doesn't mean
you can't do it
just because something is very very
difficult doesn't mean it's not um
completely worth doing and not
completely possible uh to accomplish so
I want to put that out there in your
head
um and it might change it might take a
mental shift
and own a touch on this before we get to
the money part
all the way down to 10 month old twins
formula shortages job shortages and an
insane cost of living
um yeah cost of living has gone up it's
uh and in during the inflation of the
last few years it's been
um job shortages there are more jobs
available than there are human beings in
the United States so in your particular
area that may be true
but across the country that's not it's
not accurate and there's so many unique
ways to find work these days and I'm
hearing and we've Nashville's been
beneficiary
millions and millions and millions of
people are saying hey we had dreams of
always living in California
yet it got too expensive or the work
didn't work out and we're going to move
and we had to say goodbye to family
people have said that about in the
Northeast in the Northwest and they've
been moving to my home state of Texas
I've been moving to Nashville here
they've been moving all over the place
and so it may be that season when you
look at your husband like couples and
families and have done for centuries
which is say hey we had a vision of our
life here and that vision is going to
change we need to move where the work is
and that may be the way it is right now
but to say that it's all coming down
just isn't accurate it's just not
accurate we are in there's hurting
people make no mistake about it
um but Jade we have people all the time
here 12 month old twins five kids seven
kids no kids two kids
it's just part of the I mean the the
math and the plan works every time the
math the math works you know and
here is is not quite right uh 100 a
month in savings is not going to be a
million dollars in 30 years you'd have
to invest 500 a month that's usually
kind of like the the Holy Grail that
people preach 500 a month over 30 years
at a 10 rate of return you're gonna have
a you're gonna have a million dollars
that is correct
um but we would say actually not to
invest in the S P 500 in index funds we
would say you know seek to to pick some
mutual funds that are going to
outperform that and I know a lot of
folks say all the time you can't beat
that yes you can over the last 20 years
the S P 500 has averaged more than 9.87
percent and over the last 30 years it's
it's average more than 10 percent you
have to look at the annualized rate of
return that's how we are measuring that
rate of return there so it is possible
don't let anybody steal your hope or
steal uh your reality don't let them
take your reality I love that this is
the Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
either one
guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
thank you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show give us a
shout we're talking money mental health
marriage whatever you got going on we're
here for you let's go out to Sarah in
San Francisco what's up Sarah Sarah
how are you doing today so good how are
you
I'm good what's up okay so my my
question is I went straight to culinary
school from high school cool back in
2003. thank you
um my mom took out a loan for me because
I was 17. okay uh the original loan was
30 000. we agreed to split it 50 50.
um as soon as I graduated I was giving
her money every month I was staying with
her because I didn't have the money but
I was giving her money every month I
eventually realized that she was not
paying on the student loan at all
um when I found out she apologized and
she said that she was she would start
paying I continued to give her money
every month um as you can imagine I
wasn't making very much money at that
time
um and I I then again discovered she was
not applying any of that much support
the student loan
um how much how much have you given her
so far yeah
I'm not sure exactly because I was
accounting but I
but I when when we talked I I gave her
at least five thousand okay how did how
did you give it was it a check how did
you do that I was giving her cash I was
giving her two hundred dollars oh
man every month well I was making I was
making minimum wage I was working yeah
yeah yeah at um anyways is your is your
name on the loan or your mom's yeah your
mom's name is on the loan only my mom
it's a Parent PLUS Loan so the reason
why I know now all this information is
because recently she came to me and she
brought up this loan because after a
while I just stopped giving her money
how long has it been so
2003. oh girl okay so recently she
brought up this loan and she asked me
for a lump sum money she asked me for
about twenty thousand dollars I'm like I
don't have that kind of money I can't
give you that and we didn't agree I've
been giving you money blah blah long
story short I looked into the loan she
owes over seventy thousand dollars
this is
um oh gosh I'm sorry I had to let a
little bit of my I had to let it out a
little bit scary and I don't know what
to do here's what's here's what's not
scary about it yeah okay
there is some scary but it's not I don't
think it's what you think it is okay
here's the scary
um
your you and your mom's relationship is
different from this point forward
okay okay and the sooner you come to
terms with the fact that your mother
um
did not uphold your end of the agreement
I can tell you all day I think the
agreement was Dumb and she all should
never have set that up it was it was
destined to create a wedge between a
mother and a daughter but here we are
um okay she has decided to not
um sit down and be the adult and say I
took out a loan here's every month for
the next however many years here's what
you're going to pay me here's how this
is going to work I'm going to keep a
spreadsheet I'm going to mark off every
date all that like a bank would do yeah
it you basically funded her lifestyle in
a tiny little way and then she comes
knocking on your door 20 years later
asking for twenty thousand dollars yeah
do you know who's not on the hook for
this money you Sarah none you you're not
on the hook you look you are not on the
hook for this money now this is your mom
and I know that you feel some level of
guilt or but I should probably but you
you gave her the money you gave it to
her she's retired that doesn't it
doesn't matter at this literally at this
point anything you say about to try to
like make it better I'm gonna tell you
it doesn't matter doesn't matter you
gave her the money she chose
she chose
and now for whatever reasons that she
has which don't matter she wants that
money back from you well the loan is
probably is it tripled is it triple 80
or 90 000 70
000. it's 70 000 and some change and now
she's making me feel like
here's what you know here's what you
could do she doesn't hold on she doesn't
get to you're allowing her to get inside
you and to make you feel a certain way
you decide who has permission to hurt
you period now that's harder when it's
our mom because our mom should be the
one person on the planet that's always
got our side and yours doesn't right
okay and I I hate that for you but she's
not making you feel bad you're choosing
to feel bad on her behalf
okay you gotta own that
you gotta own that okay here's what you
could do now you said to your you said
if you were really interested in
feeling very clean walking away from
this situation you said that the loan
was thirty thousand and you were
supposed to split it so that would be
15K on you now if you're telling me hey
I paid 5 000 towards this loan I know
that I paid five thousand give her
another 10K and say hey
I paid my half and that would have been
it if you wanted to do that and just say
I know I paid 15 you didn't do your
thing whatever you could do that
um but you're not on the hook for this
all right so Sarah Sarah if I'm in if
this is me like I'm just I'm fast I'm
thinking about this being my mom okay
and we sit down what I would say is
exactly what Jade said but I would I
would I would add one extra layer I
would put a payment plan in front of her
yeah and say I agreed to pay fifteen
thousand dollars of a thirty thousand
dollar loan
um I'm gonna pay you 20 back and I'm
gonna already say I've already given you
five and that's on the low end
so I'm gonna pay you fifteen thousand
dollars and here's what I can pay over
the next 12 months 15 months 24 months
and you make the payment don't hand her
any more money yes okay so directly to
the
should I give it directly to the place
will they now want my information no it
doesn't matter just get the login and
pay it say Mom the only way you're
getting this money is I sit right next
to you we log in and we pay it because
you're not handing her you're not
funding her uh ridiculousness
because she has not been a good Steward
with money so that is Ridiculousness and
you're not gonna hand her fifteen
thousand dollars to do whatever it is
that she's been doing which whatever
that was caused a student loan to Triple
all right so we're not participating in
that yeah really bad okay so here's
another thing Sarah I'm gonna give you
I'm going to give you
um a year of
FPU okay and she might not because she's
still got 55 000 left to pay off after
you write her check
and so if she wants to you can sit down
and put these videos on and y'all can
come up with a plan it's not too late
for her either we deal with folks all
the time in the 50s 60s who are figuring
it out and it's not too late but you get
to make that choice she gets to make
that choice okay so hang on the line
here we're gonna hook you up
um and hope maybe even say I'm Gonna
Give You fifteen thousand dollars which
is five grand more but you gotta sit
down and watch these videos with me
because you got 55 000 and listen if she
starts hassling you start saying oh
you're just gonna leave your mama to
what you can always stand up and walk
out the door and that's hard hard but
remember this line behavior is a
language
and if your mom chooses to swear at you
get mad at you send you on guilt trips
that you can't afford
she's telling you through her language I
don't want you around here
I don't value you and so I'm gonna hear
what you're saying through your actions
and I'm gonna head out the door until we
can have a grown-up conversation it's
going to be hard hard treading um you
have to grieve the loss of your mom or
your new relationship with your mom
because things are different now dude
money does weird things to people John
but this is why I mean I can't
money money makes people act up though
like it does but but co-signing on loans
man just I I've never seen it work well
it doesn't work I haven't seen it work
well it doesn't work co-signing is is
stupid and especially if you have listen
if you've taken a loan out with your
kids and you all have like car payment
you just pay me back or you go no no no
no no put it in a spreadsheet be adults
and say you owe me this much on this
date in this way and and and think about
this
she said she was 17 when her mom signed
that loan adults be adults and
understand that your kids were kids and
you were adulting them at that time do
not come after these folks for these
Parent Plus Loans you you signed them
parents Parent PLUS that means parent
plus your money the the best who's
paying it Bank looked at your kid and
said I'm not giving him money and you
said well you can give it to me I'm
trustworthy yeah be trustworthy be
trustworthy be trustworthy
and pay uh pay your bills parents act
like parents parents act like parents
I'm gonna have to get the Preparation H
up
and we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
if you haven't heard we recently
announced that money and marriage event
is back and this time it's going to be a
whole
weekend join Rachel Cruz and me right
here in Nashville for money and marriage
getaway in October that will have you
and your spouse feeling more aligned and
more connected than ever before the
money and marriage getaway is designed
for you and your spouse to disconnect
from everyday life
and finally after three years of being
roommates and co-managers of your house
you can focus on your marriage I've been
hearing from a lot of couples who are
struggling to find time to dedicate to
your marriage this is months out so you
got plenty of time to figure something
out this weekend long event is for you
as part of the getaway you'll have a fun
date night experience dude we're gonna
we're we're blowing it out there's gonna
be time set aside to reflect and grow
together it's gonna be some time to be
awkward and time to be weird and plenty
of encouragement and ideas from Rachel
Cruz and me and others that will help
the two of you stay on the same page
about your money and your intimacy and
your future so remember this is an
intimate three-day event so ticket
prices start at 6.99 a couple which is a
steal for a three-day marriage Retreat
here in Nashville so if you're in baby
step two this event probably is not for
you this year it will be soon go to
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your spots today man I'm going to that
it's gonna be good I'm going to that you
might be on that stage so okay okay
let's do that John
man the last thing I was about to say we
should invite our spouses and I thought
the last thing on earth my wife wants to
do is to sit in an audience and listen
to me talk about it Sam warshaw will be
there she would just want to follow up
and be like let me let me tell you what
it's like being married to that guy all
right let's go to Joshua in Raleigh uh
North Carolina what's up Joshua
hey what's going on guys partying man
what's happening
not much not much
um so just basically wanted to kind of
touch base with you guys on some
thoughts I've had circulating in my head
um I kind of
I would consider myself not in as much
debt as most people but I mean that's
subject to interpretation how much
um so right now I'm currently excuse me
I'm about
7 500 in credit card debt and then also
um I owe about 6 400 left on my car
payment for my truck payment okay um and
then I had then I had my townhouse that
I bought as well so that added into it
as well but that's basically my pool of
debt for now what do you owe on that
town home
um I think I'm at 160 that I owe now
what's it worth
uh probably about 240. 250 somewhere in
that price range cool
so what's your what are your thoughts
for today
so that's kind of where my thoughts stem
from right is that
um I've been reading up on some of the
articles on the website and then
listening to a lot of the shows and
everything and I just was trying to
figure out what would be the smartest
decision to make like would it be smart
to kind of make a seasonal change and
you know sell or or my townhouse or
whatever to eliminate all my debt and
kind of get a fresh start so to speak or
what's your monthly payment on it
um It came it comes out to about 11 60.
how much money do you bring in monthly
for income
um it's around after taxes and
everything else it's about
3 800 a month
all right it's it's close
um yeah it's around 30 I believe it was
30 31 uh what do you do for a living
uh so I work for the federal government
here I'm a financial analyst for them at
the Depot here
it's not very much money yeah are you
making 55 or 60 a year
no no no no so that's that's that was
net like bring home after uh tsp
contributions
um retirement account contributions
health insurance like all that stuff is
taken out as well okay so so you're at 3
800 after contributions
before taxes like I'm sitting at uh
around 91 000. so here's 91 and a take
home of 38.
yeah how much are you contributing to
your
um
retirement
uh so I have two different pools right
now there's the Thrift Savings Plan that
I contribute to and then there's the
other
um I believe it's First Federal Employee
Retirement something I can't remember
um What's the total contribution between
the two of those
I'm at eight percent in the tsp
um because they match up to five okay
and then
the other one is just automatic so I I'd
have to dig in a little further to see
exactly what percentages of that okay so
here's here's what we're gonna do here
here's what I would do you're calling
the Ramsay show here's the Ramsay method
yeah I would I would not sell the house
because it's not it's it's really not
the problem here the problem is pretty
small you've got thirteen thousand
almost fourteen thousand dollars of debt
I'm not gonna sell the house to get rid
of fourteen thousand dollars of debt not
when you're investing at least eight
percent into retirement and probably
more possibly double we don't know how
much so what we teach is that when we're
in baby step two which is
for all intents and purposes what you're
in when you're paying off debt we pause
investing so that we can pay off our
debt as quickly as possible
so if I were in your shoes and this is
what I believe that you should do pause
your investing so you can get this debt
paid off you're gonna have so much more
income left and you're gonna be able to
knock this out quickly do you have any
money saved in savings
uh yeah so currently I have about
uh it's it's around 800 900 right now
okay I think like in cash okay great so
let's bump that up to a thousand dollars
and get your starter emergency fund
that's baby step one and then while
you're doing that today go on to your
you know companies you know uh HR portal
wherever it is that you you manage your
contributions and let's stop that
contribution or it's the federal
government so you may need to send it
like a carrier pigeon oh that's a good
point it is the federal government yeah
uh go down to the DMV I'm just kidding
whatever that means for you to pause
that contribution that's a lot of money
left in your pocket and I know a lot of
people I'm not gonna lie and a lot of
people get they get squirrely over this
one because it's like no you know time
is on my side I need to get the compound
interest I need to get the match the
match is going to be there this is going
to take you less than a year to pay off
and so the match is going to be there
and then once one sec John and then
you're gonna have 15 percent
to invest not eight percent you can have
more and you're gonna make up for that
loss so let's just walk those baby steps
pay off the debt and then get your three
to six months and then baby step four
investing fifteen percent so I Josh I my
wife and I sat down and mapped it all
out we owed six figures
and I sold my house and because I had an
opportunity to live for free for a year
and yeah in a an apartment on campus and
so I had a unique situation where I dug
myself such a massive hole and I had an
opportunity that was just a straight
shot laser beam to get out
if you tell me hey I'm done with a town
home life I want to actually leave
Raleigh um I want to clean I want to
control all the lead I'm kind of done
with my the federal job I want to go do
you know go back into private banking or
whatever that's a whole other
conversation that's a life conversation
that if you start to transition your
life you're gonna have some free cash
after you sell your place to pay off
your debts that and that would just be
hey I've got 80 or 90 000 from the
equity of a sale I'm gonna go ahead and
pay this thing off
um but I like I I firmly believe what
she just said don't don't not for 14
Grand man I mean you're talking like a
like a couple of clicks on a website and
three or four months of dedicated work
and you're free yeah not to mention
there's a there's something to be said
about just walking yourself through that
process of paying something yeah making
those payments and realizing okay I
don't like this yeah like it doesn't
feel good paying off debt right it
doesn't feel good pausing your
retirement and when you feel that in
your body it it changes the way you do
things because you I don't want to go
back to that I don't ever want to have
to pause my my retirement contributions
again right I don't ever want to have to
sacrifice to this extent again so it's
really good to allow your yourself to
feel that and not try to bypass that
with with a quick you know sale of the
house where you can just go get another
one and Joshua you're new to Our Gang
right
uh yeah so I I'd kind of been listening
in but pretty intently for like the past
couple weeks or so okay I want you to
get ready for what's coming
you make six figures almost six figures
as a federal employee you're gonna have
an old used car in the parking lot and
your co-workers are going to make fun of
you you're going to pause spending your
co-workers are going to say what are you
doing are you trying to bankrupt
yourself do you realize how good this
we've got it here in the federal
whatever and people are going to look at
you like you're nuts because you're
paying your debts off
keep moving forward like millions and
millions of other people have walked the
path ahead of you to Freedom be the
weird guy in the parking lot man and
that's for everybody in America be the
weird person in the parking lot
and the weird person with a big bank
account we'll be right back on the
Ramsay show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love The
Show
for dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
Jade warshaw and we're taking your calls
on money life relationships work
whatever's going on in your world we're
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five before
we go to the phones there's these two
guys out here in the lobby that have
their own homemade Dave Ramsey shirts
just so you know if you ever come visit
us Dave loves a good shirt with his face
on it so there they are that is dumb
cash is king that's what I'm saying man
they did it I'm doing it right well done
guys all right to Josh in Ontario what's
up brother Josh
hey Jade hey John what's going on thanks
for taking my call today I'm glad to get
on uh get on here with you I have a
credit card question for you okay what's
going on
uh me and my wife are finally making
some Headway and we got rid of our last
credit card in January way to go we're
really enjoying it and we got everything
over to debit credit cards and then a
few things on a prepaid credit card like
our purchasing
items that needed credit cards now we
have
um a small Plumbing business and we run
ads online with an online Advertiser
and they won't accept
anything debit credit or prepaid credit
they'll only accept real credit cards
and we've got our ads off right now
um those are about 20 to 40 percent of
our
calls for the week or as long as a
plumbing business Plumbing calls so it's
um
Josh I'm gonna yeah that's a huge that's
a huge thing just to turn that spigot
off
um I can't believe they would do that
but nothing surprises me anymore
um one I would keep my eye out
uh for another service provider that's
gonna have the same values that I have
that's just going to be a thing I want
to figure out in life I want to do
business with people that
um
see the world like I do or are going to
be inclusive and aren't going to make me
jump through hoops to give them my money
it just drives me crazy rental car
company like I just make it easy for me
to pay you that's number one but the
second thing is um I'm gonna say some a
company over the air I just want to say
like there's I don't have any liability
against it this is just who I use
personally so if you were my friend and
we are having a drink I would tell you
um there's a company called privacy.com
and what I do is I put my debit card in
there once and then they give me a new
card for every online vendor that I use
so Amazon does not have my banking
information and there's a new they
provide a new card for Amazon they
provide a new card when I buy protein
shakes they provide a new card when my
wife pays for her
um Squarespace for her website for her
business so
um I probably have 40 or so different
cards with different vendors that I use
online buying shoes whatever it is
you're buying I don't want all these
other companies to have my banking info
but I think if you did something like
privacy.com you put your debit card in
there and it's going to create a card
that's gonna go to this online vendor
and it's going to be what you need the
service is completely free
I love that idea okay and if that
doesn't work that's cool if that doesn't
work which I I think that it will but
look into PayPal use PayPal card use a
stripe card use a Squarespace card
they're not credit cards you can have
them set up in debit format but if this
vendor is not in 2023 and they're not
understanding that these are real uh
payment sources you know you got to find
a new vendor yeah that's like a place
that only takes a check you know what
I'm saying like you go in there it's
like what is wrong with you guys I won't
save them online but it starts with G
and ends with o
so it's hard to get a person on yes yeah
in contact with a person who works there
it's mostly uh
and I can tell you
I'm fairly certain we use
um we have ads with them and I can
guarantee you we're not using a credit
card so I don't know how they the the
people have figured out how to do that
but there's a way I'm confident there's
ways but try privacy.com and give that a
shot and again I I've got no deal with
them I've gotten I'm not making any
money off this there's no advertisement
they're not an advertising the show
that's just who I use personally
um in my own own life and I was doing it
more for privacy issues but it sounds
like this would help you get around that
yeah that's crazy it's time to find a
new vendor I it's so strange Jay we're
like in a world where I have to ask like
do you we're in Austin and I was do you
all take cash like y'all take money
when it's hard for me to give a business
money I know you need to re-revaluate I
I should just be able to give you money
in whatever form I want to give you
money and if you're a business and
you're going no I don't like that kind
of money I want the other kind no I
don't have it okay we don't want your
business are you kidding me I'm trying
to give you money I remember I had a a
hard conversation once with a uh a
rental car company that I won't name on
air I did on my show and I finally said
hey I'm trying to give you my money
would you take it would you take my
money and no she did not all right let's
go to Daniel in h tone what's up Daniel
hey how's it going partying man what are
you up to
all right so I'm in baby step 3B and
I've got some car troubles and I need
repairs that total about fifty three
hundred dollars
yeah what happened Richard what'd you do
did you talk what happened yeah I've
been driving it I've just been driving
it I mean
what is that a new transmission a new
motor what what is that what's the 5300
it's a new transmission and then also a
front crankshaft crankshaft seal and a
new timing chain and it just started
making a Chewbacca ground when I make a
left turn too it's like you're eating
too much Taco Bell that noise is you
that's you what's the car worth the
um
so with the transmission needing to be
replaced I'm I'm guessing a fair price
which in a private sale would yield
about 2700.
if it's in very good condition it's 3
800.
so if
you want to pay 5300 for the car that
would that's at this point not even
worth three thousand dollars
I made the mistake of getting attached
to it
I wouldn't do that I'd probably start
looking for something new these are
major major repairs are you married
uh uh Divorced with one child okay do
you have a pet
no you should get one of those and get
attached to it
not your failing vehicle my brother I
mean here's the thing you don't have any
debt you're in baby step 3B how much how
quickly can you cash flow something
that's better than three a three
thousand dollar car
I mean I could just take it from the
emergency fund for now and then
but can you add any of your cash flow to
it so that you're not pulling too much
from your
yeah yeah I mean I would say like two
months of cash flow and then whatever I
could get for the the car that's going
out man I'm doing that yeah you can get
a 7 500 card that way yeah spend six six
to eight thousand dollars get you
something better than this and uh be be
on your Merry way that's what I'm doing
John absolutely have a ceremony sounds
like you love this car
get it a nice oil change tell that you
love it something happened in this car
[Music]
get rid of it my man drive safe on those
Houston roads this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right back
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show listen if you're
a new listener and you want to dive
deeper into the Ramsay baby steps if you
listen to the show and you're brand new
to us and you're like what are we
talking about they sound like weirdos
you are correct they sound like they're
an occult you are correct sound like
they have different advice than
everybody else yes if you want to learn
more go to ramseysolutions.com and click
on the get started button here's the
deal we're going to help you figure out
the next best step for your financial
Journey based on exactly where you are
today
some people have a lot of money in the
bank they got money coming they're broke
some people owe six figures some people
owe half a million dollars like Jade and
Sam did wherever you are go to
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
and we will line you up with the exact
approach tailored for you
um and by the way a great way if you're
been with us for a long time
Ralph Mendoza some of our other gang
who's been with us forever forever
a great gift to people in your
neighborhood and community that would
never know about the show otherwise is
if you will go hit the Subscribe button
click the you know the leave a review
click the thumbs up whatever it is
if you subscribe to it it kicks it up in
the algorithms whether you're on
Instagram whether you're on tick tocks
or whether you're on YouTube whatever
platform it kicks it up into algorithms
and it puts the show in front of more
people and it's a it's a no cost way of
helping us out but more importantly
helping out your neighbors so please hit
the Subscribe button today all right
let's go to Hampton in Atlanta Georgia
what's up Hampton Hampton I like it yes
sir yes ma'am what up
not too much uh how are y'all we're
doing good doing great man
great yeah so I'll listen on YouTube
here and there and kind of just wanted
to call in and see if I could get
y'all's opinion on my certain you know
current situation so what's the
situation
so um 29 I'll be 29 in April so I'm
still 28 but uh I purchased my first
home four years ago on my 25th birthday
cool and you know it was a good time to
buy I have a good amount of equity about
150 000 in equity and I was wondering if
now is the time for me to uh upgrade at
home I've never really wanted to live in
a neighborhood and that's kind of where
I'm at now and I'm just wondering if now
is a good time to sell my house to
purchase another one given my financial
situation do you have any debt
I have no debt whatsoever just the house
I owe 165 on it I got it from 181.
and it's worth about 320. great
excellent so you know
I mean I money wise there's nothing
really stopping you I mean of course you
want to purchase it based on those
parameters that we set we don't want it
to we don't want the payment to be any
more than 25 of your take-home pay and
that's with insurance and everything all
combined
um on a 15-year fixed have you found
something that that's within those
parameters that you're looking at
so that and that's what makes this kind
of tough for me and makes me second
guess it um I'm currently I'm
self-employed I own my own company and
uh the way my taxes are structured I
would have to go bank statement loans so
um we're talking eight nine percent
interest and right now I'm currently on
an FHA that's 2.75 interest can you
explain to me when you said bank
statement loan I'm actually not familiar
with that
um so
you know conventional loans and FHA
Loans are based off you know your your
income your net income right
um and I just write off a lot through my
business so I wouldn't qualify right now
for conventional yeah and that's what I
want you to get I want you to get a
conventional loan and if you can't get
it I wouldn't do this yeah and if you're
if you are sketching around your taxes
don't do that either man
no I'm definitely not doing that it's
just yeah I have a question everything I
can write off currently I have a
question from that because
um Sam and I were business owners and I
had a zero credit score at the time and
his was dropping down to zero and we
were able to
get a conventional loan 15-year fixed no
I think what Hampton Hampton tell me if
I'm wrong I think what he's saying is
the way he is able to write off
everything it looks like his business
makes about 1400 a year oh okay okay
okay okay okay so we're I see what
you're doing there and so so now now
it's coming back to bite you under the
on the butt because it looks like your
money makes your business makes no money
all right so two thoughts I'm glad that
this bit you in the butt because your
butt needed biting that's Thing One and
Thing Two is hey you gotta pay your
taxes and you got to do it right do it
right
um here's what Hampton here's what I
would say
um I want to always challenge when
somebody says I'm ready to move up
hmm we have a culture that says you just
now that you make this much money you
should be driving this car and I
wholeheartedly reject that it sounds
like you're also ready to change your
lifestyle it must have it might have
been really cool to have a town home
down downtown or a loft downtown and now
the idea of just having a suburb and
laying low is pretty cool and having
things be a little bit more chill a bit
a little bit closer to work you're
talking about a lifestyle change and so
I just want to be careful about the
language like it's time to move up I I
just reject that man if you want to get
a nice house get a nice house but get
don't do it because you're on a
treadmill of any sort um and if you want
to change your life change your life but
as Jade said man it doesn't sound like
your business is if the bank looks at
you and says I'm not going to give you
any money unless we do a special deal
that's going to cost you a bunch of
extra dollars for us to feel safe about
this risk
then that's the bank telling you we
really don't want to take uh your money
right now because we don't trust you and
if the bank doesn't trust you then
sometimes that's a sign that you're not
ready to buy another house yet so just
over this quick little break I was while
John was talking I was looking at these
bank statement loans so the difference
is for small businesses if you don't
want to show your tax returns and you
don't want to show your net income all
you do is show your bank statement
because at that point it's like it's
just based off of how much money has
been in your bank account so I see okay
yeah but that but think how sketched
that can get because if you're if you
were a construction I can deposit 50
Grand in that account show that to the
bank and then turn around and buy forty
nine thousand dollars worth of materials
for that job yeah and yeah if you're
running pretty tight like this so yeah
dude
Hampton it sounds like you need some
more work and it sounds like you need to
get your profit margin way way way up
yeah way up 15 15-year fixed
conventional loan is what we would would
teach here yeah so I'd stay put my
brother stay put yep all right let's run
out to Calvin real quick in Michigan
Calvin right up against the clock so get
right to your question what's up
hi um thank you guys for taking my call
I really appreciate it I'm 19 and I've
been listening to Dave Ramsey for like
two or three years I found him on
YouTube on accident and was honestly the
best thing I've ever done and I I'm no
no dad no credit card guy but my
question is
so I'm about to graduate uh Community
College with a Associates in business
and I want to go into marketing and I
live with my mom I don't have any debt
and I was wondering if I should can um
if I should start in the going into the
field or if I should do another two
years at
um at a college in I mean it's more
money but um I want to start saving for
a house and I'm because I'm I'm crazy
and I want to pay for a house in full
that's not crazy uh you need to get
Calvin you need to get a job
and um
both I I I finished two phds with a
full-time job and little kids it'll make
you busy but if you decide hey I need to
go get a degree and or the business I
work for I love says hey you need to go
get some extra credentials or you need
to get some extra training you can do
that while working yeah I'd get the job
first and see if they'll pay if anything
pay for your education that's right
and I'd focus on one thing at a time
don't do it if you're not going to pay
cash for it I don't want you going into
debt for a four-year degree or any
degree for that matter and then it also
sounds like you've kind of got a lot
floating around in your brain because
you're also talking about buying a house
so let's kind of like focus on let's
focus on one thing at a time and make it
a clear decision there and make sure all
the decisions that you're making are
lining you up to go down the path that
you want to go down as opposed to just
this sounds good I'll do that well now
this sounds good I'm gonna go do that
does that make sense see if the job that
you want you can get with just this
two-year Associates and Calvin find some
folks hang on the line here Kelly's
going to send you a copy of our friend
Ken Coleman's book proximity principle
all you need to get connected to a
couple of folks who do Marketing in your
area and they do it at a scale that you
want to do it they run an agency they're
a partner in an agency or they're doing
it local like small time whatever you
envision yourself five or ten years from
now doing that take them out to Coffee
it could be someone from your church
could be someone from your local
neighborhood just read retouch someone
on LinkedIn take them out to Coffee ask
them what their life is like and ask
them the credentialing question and
they're going to give you a much much
more
um direct answer especially for your
regional market there
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
cschm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right if you're planning to
move soon we know that it can be
expensive and for that fact I've got
good news for you guys our studio
sponsor which is PODS moving and storage
they want to help you guys move for free
can you believe that all you have to do
is get a quote at pods.com Ramsay
between February 20th and March 3rd in
order to enter to win this it's that
simple you're going to pods.com Ramsay
between February 20th and March 3rd now
one listener is going to get a free move
which is valued up to five thousand
dollars and ten thousand dollars in Cold
Hard Cash baby that's what I'm talking
about if you're following the math
that's a total value of fifteen thousand
dollars John can I just tell y'all when
we moved from Florida to Tennessee
I had no idea how much this would cost
oh dude we moved from Texas to Tennessee
I basically like hey you can pay us or
we'll just take one of your kids man
what these quotes were like 19 and 20
000 I was sick now look pods just made
this even easier with flexibility that
you need the control that you want in
the customer service that you deserve oh
gosh I wish this had been there when we
were moving if you're looking for a
company that will help you with your
move on your terms then pods is the only
I'm talking only Ramsay trusted moving
provider out there so go to pods.com
Ramsay and enter for your chance to win
a free move and ten thousand dollars in
Cold Hard Cash today that's pods.com
Ramsey all right let's go to Amy in
Grand Rapids what is up Amy how we doing
hi thanks so much guys for having me you
got a mind calling yeah um so my husband
and I have two houses
um we are living at my house and we are
fixing his house and
um we are all Newlyweds
what's that are y'all Newlyweds
about four years will be four years this
July have you all been living in
separate houses
sorry we have lots of questions and okay
no problem yeah we both had a house when
we got married
um but his house needed to be repaired
and so we were living at my house for
what have you all done for four years
with his house
then we've been working on it
um so we had actually taken out a like a
repair loan and then we've also we've
been paying that back and then we've
also paid cash for like the remaining
portion of his house and his house is
getting very close to being done
um and so we still have my house I have
a mortgage on my house
um and we have about 11 000 left to pay
for the remainder of the construction
repair that we have for his house how
much is the mortgage on your house
uh we still have about 47 000 for my
house uh okay and now on his you said
the repairs were 11k is there anything
else mortgage wise on that
nope nope his house is otherwise paid
for what's it worth
um I think uh we met with a realtor we
haven't had an appraised recently but
it's probably about 125 to 150 000.
what's yours worth
um mine was about 89 000. do you guys
have any other debts
yes we have I have student loans of 30
000 approximately that's it between the
two of you
uh yeah well we have the 30 000 for my
student loans my house is 47 and the
repair loan for his house is about 11.
and that's that's the entire amount of
debt we have currently
all right I don't love this situation
I'm not gonna lie I don't like that you
guys have two homes with a mortgage
um what's the plan like what's the
ultimate plan with these homes
because you don't need two houses
right that's exactly that's my question
too because we have um his house is
almost ready to be moved into
um my house is right next to a lake and
so we have thought about like uh in the
future uh potentially like putting it as
like an Airbnb house
um so that's kind of what we've gone
back and forth on and would it be like
financially profitable
um to keep it and operate it in that way
because his house is nearly paid for
um paying off my house I mean if that's
a business venture you guys want to get
into when the time comes right now I'm
focused on the debt I'm looking at when
you when you line up this money like
this I'm like all right or how do we get
out of debt um I don't like that you
have 30k of student loans sitting around
and I don't like that you have two
mortgages on top of it so my first
indication is can we get rid of one of
them can we focus on one thing can we
pay off his with the quickness
um does that make sense
yes I would love to see y'all moving go
ahead go ahead
oh you're saying to uh pay off his uh
his remainder of the construction loan
at 11 000. I'm just saying I would love
to see you guys it sounds like if you
sold one of these houses and moved into
one a you would dramatically simplify
your lives B you'd owe nobody anything
on the planet you'd have no mortgage no
nothing and then the ROI of this you
know the big buzzword is cash flow cash
flow cash flow
you you free up because you know don't
owe anybody anything you free up about
that much and you can save up over the
next couple of years and buy your 89 000
house back in cash and not the same one
obviously but you you set yourself up a
life with very little risk at that at
that at that point does that make sense
versus having two mortgages 30 Grand in
student loan debt we're hoping fingers
crossed the government just will wipe
away for us they're not going to right
and you see what I'm saying you set
yourself up and a really cool thing
but man y'all are making your life
complicated it's complex
yeah so okay well that's helpful um like
I said we were kind of just debating on
whether like to keep it as like a
potential like Airbnb in
um because we live in a town where
um about 20 minutes from like Lake
Michigan and so oh yeah that is a huge
profit
um I think if you add Airbnb to the mix
right now you're further complicating a
situation and you're adding risk to it
I'm not an Airbnb expert I'll be the
first one to tell you I'm not an Airbnb
expert but I know that there's a lot of
costs associated with that I don't think
it's something that you could just walk
in and be like we're just gonna make a
killing I think that you have to think
through it on every side
um if you guys if you if y'all went
crazy just went Stone mad
how quick could you pay off the 30 000
bucks and that eleven thousand dollars
the Forty forty one thousand bucks how
quickly could y'all get that together
and pay it off
um uh it would probably be a little
while because we have
um a lot of expenses we're both we're
paying for my house and then paying for
his house and we also have daycare which
is astronomically expensive so how many
kids do you have the maintenance we have
one child okay and can I ask one more
question I don't want to sound like I'm
interrogating you but do you have any
liquid cash
uh yeah we have about uh I think about
14 000. okay here's what I'm gonna say
to you and I hope you don't take it as
me coming down on hard on you but you
called us y'all are doing the most and
also doing the least all right you're do
you have like this grand master plan but
I don't feel like it's planning for you
like the math is not mathing for you
because you didn't call here talking
about we've got so much money we just
don't know what to do with it you called
me with a pile of debt and so because of
that I I gotta teach you what I know
Works which is the baby steps that's
what I know works it's helped millions
of people and right now you guys are so
far over just all over the place so we
would talk about like the 14k you could
why don't you have his house paid off
instantly it's eleven thousand dollars
have a paid for mortgage for the love of
God and then right you're free
mm-hmm right and now walk through the
baby steps pay off that eleven thousand
dollar loan and now you've got you know
three thousand left and let's pile that
keep a thousand aside for uh you know
your starter emergency fund and let's
plow through that next twenty nine
thousand dollars of debt or twenty eight
thousand at that point of student loan
debt plow through that and at that point
you've just got your mortgage and it's a
normal size actually it's not a normal
size mortgage it's tiny and let's walk
through these baby steps the good thing
is you're not owing you know you don't
owe 200 and 300 000 on a mortgage you
know what I'm saying you don't have two
and three hundred thousand dollars of
student loan debt so you guys are
playing patty cake with this and
extending it and making it all weird
where this could be really simple and
cut and dry and you could have one
mortgage by morning
I love that plan for you and then you do
have yeah you see what I'm saying why
don't you like that Amy something
doesn't stick with you
no no I was listening um so I I guess
when we first had got together and put
our um we actually have been doing today
of course we've gotten away from a bit
no this is not the baby steps this is
not the baby steps
I gotta cut you off on that work the
plan that I just gave you to work and
you guys are gonna be sitting pretty you
are sitting on Lake Michigan I went
there as a kid it's beautiful and I
think you could probably do well with an
Airbnb there but let's do it in the
right order so that you don't put
everything at risk for this dream of
owning
real estate this is the Ramsay show
we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by Jade warshaw
is your marriage going sideways give us
a shout are you struggling with your
mental health or got money questions or
you just don't know what to do with your
kids holler at us triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go out to
Chris in Springfield Missouri what's up
Chris how we doing
okay man
um before I start I just wanted to say
thank you to you guys and everybody at
Ramsey Solutions
um since I was younger you got a really
positive impact on me and my financial
decision so cool I just want to say it
for that well thanks brother I
appreciate it man
um I think it would be important just to
give you guys a little bit of context on
me and just my background before I ask
my questions so um basically I've always
been really good with my money over a
few years I was able to save up like 50
um 40 000 of it was on my savings and
then 10 000 of it I had invested in
mutual funds
um I also am going to school
I like to say better than debt free
because I'm going totally free good for
you that's awesome scholarships and a
work study and stuff like that um
so with that though
um
during uh all of that time that I was
accumulating those funds I was in an
abusive relationship
um
pretty much like anything negative you
could think of uh I'm sorry she dissed
all that out so it uh it kind of messed
me up and when I was finally able to get
out of it
um as a way of coping I guess I started
spending my money on a lot of stuff
sorry
um are you all right
over like maybe eight months now uh
totally drained
all my savings and uh I've pulled out
all my investments and I've just spent
it all on crap and um
I probably only have like I don't know
maybe a little under two thousand
dollars now okay uh
so I just I don't really know where to
go from here because my plan originally
was once I get my bachelor's
um you know the deal that I kind of have
with my parents is like once I'm done
with college and I'm out of the house
and that's just what it is
um and I was going to go to grad school
and everything but
I'm just not really sure how to like go
about doing that and just what to do
financially anymore
so I think
um you know Dave's been saying for years
your money is just a reflection of
what's going on in your heart and mind
and soul in life
and so right now I want to move the
money conversation over it's a big it's
a big neon sign
letting you know that you're not all
right right now
and I want to tell you
having sat with people I can't count how
many people I've sat across the table
with they're sitting next to
who are trying to figure out who they
are after leaving an abusive
relationship
and the chaos of I still love that
person but that person deeply hurt me in
a number of different ways I lost part
of myself and I don't even know what
that means and how to get that back all
of that stuff is all chaotic in a mess
and
yeah man you you got out your spending
card and went went bananas what I would
tell you is the sun came up today right
that's true yeah you got 2 000 bucks
and I don't want to minimize you're
gonna have some grief and you're
probably gonna have some uh resentment
you're gonna have all that stuff all
those feelings dude listen to me they're
right they're fine they're good
they're right
the only thing you can do from this
moment forward
you can't go back and edit sentences
that have already been written they got
a period at the end of them
you were in love with somebody that hurt
you deeply you broke up
you spent forty eight thousand dollars
in a spending spree to wallpaper over
depression and grief and sadness
and here you are
and the things you told us leading up to
those moments tell me that you are a
strong kid and that you're a driven guy
and you have accomplished a ton we we
very few of the adults that call into
this show have fifty thousand dollars
access fifty thousand dollars cash my
brother very few people call in and say
hey I figured out how to do college for
free
and so you had a plan and that plan is
going to be different now you had a plan
you're just gonna Waltz into grad school
into your next job because you had a big
nest egg we don't have that anymore so
cool
nothing about what you've told me
suggests that you suddenly have lost the
ability to work really hard because I
know that's who you are
and nothing you've told me says suddenly
you're dumb because you're not
what you have told me is you're gonna
have to spend some see a season grieving
this you're gonna have to go spend some
time with a counselor
okay and I would tell you that if you
were my best friend or you're my brother
okay okay and you're gonna spend some
time healing and you're gonna spend some
time here's the here's the uncomfortable
truth about abusive relationships that
people often don't hear it's real easy
to be on the outside of that and to
demonize the abuser what people often
fail to take into account is the person
being abused loses trust in themself I
don't even trust me anymore and now
you've got 48 000 reasons to further not
trust you right what you're going to
have to do is learn to build trust in
Chris again
that's just going to take some practice
my man
okay okay
yeah
so here's the deal I want you to hang on
the line here are you you're still in
school right
yeah I I got a year left okay here's why
that's not that's fantastic I'm so happy
because that means you have access to a
student Counseling Center that's going
to be outstanding and in a time when um
it's very hard to just call a therapist
off the street and get an appointment
you're going to be able to do that so I
want you to make that call today in
exchange for making that call
uh we're gonna send you can Coleman's
get clear assessment we're going to send
you his book paycheck to purpose and I'm
going to send you my book own your past
change your future
and that my whole book is what happens
when you are sitting down you realize
you're an ash and how do you take that
next step out okay I'm grateful for the
call man and we love you and we'll help
you every step of the way here I just
need you to hear me say you're not
broken you're not dysfunctional you
didn't do anything wrong I mean you blew
a bunch of money and I would laugh with
you in high five if we're sitting at the
table
um and also I don't believe Jade I don't
believe in the phrase too soon that's
just kind of me but I I'd high five of
you and then we would get on with okay
what comes next but you got some healing
to do oh yeah
that's tough
I think you covered it I'm not gonna add
or take away
how I'm trying to think of how I've
wrestled with moments of my life Jade
when I've just flat out set my values on
fire or I've fought out done something I
said I wasn't gonna do or I've spent my
time poking my finger at people who do
things and then all of a sudden I look
up six months later and I'm that guy now
right right you know it's tough I was
sitting here trying to think of a
similar situation like when have I been
there like what have I and it's you can
really live in the past and wallow in
like man what I did I spent forty eight
thousand dollars how could I have done
that but then it's like what are you
gonna do next
and I I I think as a as a culture we
have two narratives one is you're always
going to be the worst thing you you've
ever done the worst thing ever happening
you're always gonna be the dumbest thing
you've ever done and then the other one
is if you have feelings and you're a
coward and a wimp and you're weak you
just suck it up and grind it and I think
that's nonsense I think the world is
desperate for a new Third Way which is
we're gonna spend some time feeling sad
and we're gonna have some grief
um you went through hell
and you did some dumb stuff yeah let's
just acknowledge it yeah and then
we're gonna get the right people around
us and because we can't do it alone
we've got the right people around us and
then we're going to take the next
crooked wobbly step forward to wherever
it is we're going right yeah progress
not necessarily Perfection nobody's out
here doing things perfect we're all just
trying to
just trying to make some kind of
progress forward right ah I mean George
Campbell tells us he's perfect his hair
is perfect his hair is perfect it's high
it's high and tight well you should see
the hair dryer he has back there I've
never seen it it's the he actually
converted an old air conditioner um it's
really an extraordinary
I need to get on that then well they
have a special plug in there it's like a
220. it's incredible but hey that's
another hour in the books here on the
Ramsey Show be kind to one another
pay off your debts we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work they love and build actual
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by Jade warshaw we
are taking your calls on life and money
and marriage and whatever else is going
on your kids work all of it triple eight
eight two five five two two five is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to Brad and the Bay
Tampa Florida what's up Brad
hey thanks for taking my call guys you
got it what's happening
and brother I've got an easy question
and a hard question my easy question is
this do you guys know how awesome you
really are oh do you know how awesome
you really are I accept I accept Brad
and I also did it I know that that means
the next question is going to be real
real bad it is you are you buttering us
up I am man I'm setting you up for the
kill oh what have you done Brad what
have you done
oh no it's it's not well okay so let's
get to the tough part right
so I'm a pastor of a really really great
church in Tampa Bay
um I inherited a mess sadly and I've
been yeah I've been here nine years
um it didn't take me long to find out
that the church had every
financial and immoral Scandal that you
can imagine we've been through a lot
we've grown a lot
um if you can it's such a sad story but
if you can imagine when Ministries go
through things like this there is always
a financial
um repercussion that is behind that type
of Scandal correct so here's my story
the brief version we started with 1.2
million dollars of debt the deacons
didn't know we had it
the church didn't know we had it and I
found it out when I actually arrived
here as Pastor I did not even know when
I came here that we had this debt was it
secured debt or is it is it frivolous or
is it on a building project what's the
Dead on
it was 1.2 million in secured debt
mortgage uh it was another 300 000
almost 300 000 unsecured debt uh
florists a host of other different
things and so
um
the short version of it is we have
gotten rid of every unsecured debt uh
crater that we had
we've worked the mortgage down in seven
years we've worked it down from 1.2
million to just over 600 000. Wow way to
go man
um yeah and so here's where I'm at this
is
this is kind of a you know a problem now
I've been reading the headlines that it
looks like the interest rate may be
going up three times possibly by the end
of this calendar year
and I don't know what to do we we have
there's no debt snowball that I'm aware
of that we could do at this point all we
have left is our mortgage right it's
about six thousand dollars it's a little
a little over six thousand dollars a
month that we're paying into this of
course you know the situation where the
interest rate Rising last year if we do
that again three times this year
uh where you're just you know it's just
hurting us it's just really an anchor
around our neck is the debt on an
adjustable arm
uh no it's not so are you talking about
the increase in interest rates will
negatively impact the tithing
yeah we're trying to figure out why your
interest rate on the mortgage would be
higher
I'm sorry I might have gotten that wrong
the interest rate every time it goes I'm
not sure about that terminology but the
interest rate every time it goes up it
is causing the payment that we are
making to do less the principal and more
so your rate is adjustable it sounds
like yeah it's called adjustable rate
mortgage which is the absolute worst
kind because it it yeah yeah that's what
a mess so we have that here's the good
news we're sitting on 7.2 Acres of real
estate in Tampa Bay okay
um we have no other debt other than the
typical Church expenses so on and so
forth how big is your charge of 600
and we run about a hundred hundred and
fifty okay
wow you guys made a lot of sorry I just
need to acknowledge the yeah I don't
know if we could go in a new term here
but we called it project Anaconda
squeezing and squeezing and squeezing
you sure did we had to say no to so many
things and so we're doing well you know
spiritually there's unity in the church
the church is with me the church is
growing it's it's beautiful I mean it's
amazing how you know we really have seen
God just turn this place around it's
really emotional for me
um has anybody left to do at this point
has any is it is it possible to
refinance out of that adjustable rate
mortgage and into something that's a
fixed rate
it's possible that we could do that but
I I actually spoke with a uh a friend of
mine who who advised against that uh I
I'm not exactly sure if that's the best
way to do it or if if my other solution
which is to take the money that we have
and just attack the debt even if it
causes us to have a low balance in our
accounts you know for example right now
our Christian School we have about 225
thousand dollars in that account we have
an emergency fund of fifty thousand
dollars that's been set aside
um we have of a little over a hundred
thousand dollars in our general fund we
have so we have some money so my
question is and we do this this
fundraiser every May to attack the debt
um so my question is should we just stay
the course
um it looks like in about six six and a
half seven years will be paid off yeah
but if we keep throwing chunks of money
at this is that the best solution to
avoid interest or should we or should I
suggest to our church our own elders and
deacons that we
nearly empty our accounts and just
really just go for it I don't know that
I would empty the accounts I think that
you do need to have some money set aside
um because it's it's not your personal
finances yeah so I would not I wouldn't
empty accounts I would stay the course
and I would get with all of the planning
committees and every committee and and
talk about how we raise funds
and just get really crazy about doing
events doing anything that you can
um to raise money and just keep
attacking this debt you know if it was
personal debt we would talk about side
hustling and going out and finding ways
to make money and I kind of want to
translate that to you like how what are
ways that this church can bring in
income what are ways that you can fire
people up to start giving more
um and I'm a very I'm a very careful
pastor about funds because I don't want
to be I don't want to be the money
grubbing guy absolutely many of those
guys and I don't want to be that guy but
let me let me tell you the other side of
it let me tell you because I'm I'm that
way too okay I grew up my dad was a
homicide detective and he quit and
became a minister and I got to see what
life was like behind the curtain I'm
like you okay
also
there's people who would be deeply
blessed and fortunate within your church
if they were asked specifically for an
opportunity to give yep
and I I won't speak I I want to keep it
private but my pastor came recently and
said hey here's a particular need that
um and I said as long as nobody ever
knows I'm in and it was a great gift to
me and my wife
and so what I would tell you is don't
Rob your church of the opportunity to
step up and do things
um that they never thought possible both
collectively and individually and it may
be that this is the season you've got to
get over that a little bit the other
thing is
also the headlines are telling us aliens
have landed they're telling us all kind
of stuff man there's there's a there's a
point when being over informed is
unhealthy I put the I put the
put the newspaper down and let's build a
plan to pay this debt off in the next 24
months let's do it man greater things
are yeah free scream on this stage we'll
be right back on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right folks a lot of you have questions
about taxes we get it taxes are
confusing
Heaven Help Us if we just made it simple
to help you get a better handle on them
let's unpack a question from one of our
listeners my husband passed away this
year and literally everything is
different for me now yeah I've got his
final tax return crazy income changes
and significant donations from
establishing a scholarship in his name
I'm nervous about filing first off I'm
heartbroken with you
um golly it's hard so sorry
we understand that things seem
overwhelming right now
and when things feel overwhelming it's
important to realize that you're not
alone
you're gonna the sun's gonna come up on
the other side of this thing especially
if you got people around you when you go
through a major life change it's best to
get a tax Pro in your corner I just and
have a similar situation I didn't have a
significant loss but some significant
changes in my life this year so this
year I reached out for a tax Pro myself
situation like this can mean a different
filing status tax bracket forms
calculations you name it an experience
Pro will know how to handle the
complexities of your situation so you
have peace of mind knowing everything is
taken care of a Ramsay trusted tax Pro
like one of our endorsed local providers
can answer your questions and help you
get your taxes filed go to
ramseysolutions.com taxpro to learn more
that's ramsesolutions.com
taxpro let's go out to Debbie in the HBC
Huntington Beach what's up Debbie how we
doing
hi I'm doing well how are you doing
great what's happening
I'm hoping that I can get some advice
from the two of you if that's okay we'll
tell you what we think it may not be
great but we'll give it a shot speak for
yourself John what's up
so my husband and I we recently bought a
condo a little over a year ago our
mortgage right now is about 4 500 a
month well my husband recently got laid
off from his position about a month ago
now so it's only my income that's coming
in
um which is around 5 000 ish a month
give or take yikes we do have our three
to six month emergency fund fully funded
we have no debt but we do have a baby on
the way here because why not right why
not
why not and my my and my husband has one
year left in his master's program that
he's currently in what's he studying and
we're not taking out he is going to get
his MBA I'm really proud of him he has
one more year left and the goal was that
we weren't going to take out any loans
so we've been paying um for that
ourselves okay now without with all that
being said
um my parents do have a back house and
they have offered for us to live there
rent free for about a year or two just
to help us save
um talked about it with my husband and
he's kind of against the idea he thinks
we might get penalized for capital gains
tax in the future and that he's
confident that he's going to be finding
another position here soon me on the
other hand I think maybe it might be a
good idea and potential good opportunity
since
um we're not currently emotionally
attached to this current condo that
we're living in anyway
um and it may provide us with a better
safety net knowing that we don't have
this mortgage hanging overhead and that
we could save for possibly about a year
or two to potentially put down on a home
that we really love so just trying to
get some advice here on on what you all
think oh go ahead no you go ahead I was
gonna say it
it sounds like you're scared
yes uh or scared maybe
um
not being the full truth it sounds like
you're terrified
um I'm trying to put myself in your
situation you're working so hard you may
have even had secret quiet thoughts of
staying at home when you have this baby
you're having a baby and all of a sudden
your husband gets laid off and you'll
have a really expensive condo welcome to
Huntington Beach and so
man suddenly there's an out of nowhere
you have to go to the bathroom really
bad and an exit ramp shows up on the
highway and you're like let's take this
one let's take this one and your
husband's like how about we wait till
there's a gas station with lights and so
now y'all are in a disagreement what
kind of work does he do
he does
uh um what what are the chances he has a
new job in the next 30 to 60 days
I mean I know he's diligently applying
to like multiple places per day so um
has had a few interviews lined up
nothing's um come to fully play out just
of yet and it's been about a month so
how much cash do you have working
working home
um well right now we have about forty
thousand dollars in our savings
all right and how much is it costing the
cash flow this Masters each month
right now
um because he did get a scholarship it's
about seven to eight thousand dollars
per quarter now come June
um that's the scholarship money is going
away so it'll be a full 12 000. I don't
want to buy the
I'm sorry come June you said
come June and was the plan to take that
out of the 40K or it was just to come
out of your incomes
the plan was it for um to come out of
our income if we needed to tap into the
savings a little bit then we could but
we always make sure we fund it back
right away
it may be a season and this happened
often students didn't know this was
happening but um I can tell you it
happens across the board in program
after program after program after
program from graduate schools to
doctoral programs to law schools and
everything in between it may be that
he's to take a leave of absence for the
summer because y'all you guys can't I I
don't I don't feel comfortable with you
sprinting off into the back House of
your mom's house simply because
um it feel that feels really
short-sighted that feels like you're
terrified and the thought of that feels
warm like a blanket but you're not
addressing some of the underlying issues
here and I think if you hang on in 60
days it sounds like he's he's not a guy
that's just sitting at home waiting for
somebody to call it's not like he's out
there hustling and in this current
economy I think he's gonna be able to
find a job but it may be that we need to
push off school we had all these dreams
of graduating this semester we're going
to it's going to be another semester and
that's fine but right now you don't need
to you can't you can't pull 12 grand out
of your savings account at this point
and how pregnant are you
um I'm naturally due in June as well
yeah I would definitely take a leave yep
got to okay yeah and and
in my mind if he's taking a leave you've
got I mean you guys are up against it
with you making 5 000 a month and you
know
you have a leave coming up here soon as
well it tell him to keep busting but to
find work but in the meantime find
anything that's right in the meantime
whatever he needs to do to keep money
coming in because I don't think you guys
need to get out of this house I think
it's just a matter of like like sewing
it together for now like putting a patch
on it for now and then it's gonna it's
gonna work itself out if you get up on
it like if you're three three months
down the pipe and it's like all right
there's nothing which I don't see any
reason why there would be like I feel
like you guys can just bust it out of
this but I you know there is a there's a
shelf life to this plan as well so if if
three months comes and for some reason
your guy's not finding any work call us
back because then it's time to find a
new plan but there's no reason why he
shouldn't be up and working doing
something bringing in enough income for
you guys to work this out and um and
that sounds like the beauty to me jade
because Debbie if I'm not mistaken is it
your parents house right
mm-hmm so what's another two months
right test it out
yeah that is true like the house isn't
going anywhere and they're not going
anywhere so you can always do this June
one right you can always move in right
before the baby's born and you can tell
him sorry you waited too long to get a
job so and I'm super pregnant so you got
to move everything by yourself yeah like
y'all can still do that
um June one
I think both of you need to sit down and
come up with okay here's plan for 30
days and 60 days and at the end of 60
days I'm gonna start feeling less and
less safe and Debbie I really it's
important now as you head into this when
you sit down and talk to him the
conversation is not about what he's not
doing
the conversation is I'm really really
scared
and I don't feel safe in this home with
a 4 500 mortgage and I'm making five
thousand bucks and I'm exhausted I'm
about to take a leave I'm about to have
a baby and all these things I'm scared
and we do have an out but I want to plan
a 30-day 60-day plan that says here's
gonna be the trigger when we say okay
you didn't get a job in 60 days you
didn't get a job in 30 days we're taking
a leave you didn't get a job in 60 days
we're gonna call Mom and Dad and see if
that's an out for us but get that stuff
on paper and that's going to help you
feel a little bit less scared yep a
little bit less scared with the plan get
that budget Titan right and find out
exactly what he needs to be making to
make this work there you go this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right so Austin is producing the show
James Childs out today Austin we got a
clip that we haven't seen yet and this
is Jonathan actor Jonathan Myers right
Jonathan Majors on Stephen Colbert's
show and he's got a unique take on the
way he does life and you wanted us to
react to it
I'm almost pastor and she was very clear
about
um safety you know she was saying no
drinking no drugs no sex every time I
left the house started drinking no drugs
no sex to get on the plane to go to
college I had to say no drinking no
drugs or sex before I went to security
my entire life
um but the drinking was a thing and she
always said you know baby just make sure
you know you don't think about watch
your cup watch your glass and uh I I
kept that in mind and you know for
safety but also you know what that meant
you know and what is that what does that
now it means you know your cup mine your
cup
you're a vessel nobody can fill you up
nobody can pour you out you do that
yourself and so holding on to this is a
reminder that you know eating this
craziness that's happening you know
my self-esteem is my self-esteem you
know nobody can make me no one can big
me up as it were or tear me down
interesting what you got John come on
John my first thought is one I love
um whether you agree with the message or
not I love intentional parents yeah who
give their kids
memorable things that get them through
sticky moments in their life I love that
because when he said no drinking no
drugs no sex I was like do we have the
same mom because I feel like that's all
I heard growing up my gosh all I heard
was my dad's I'm just kidding I was
gonna say something awful so um so I
like that the second thing I like is
the sense of ownership over his body the
sense of ownership over his uh
intentions that at the end of the day
he's going to take full responsibility
and live an intentional life if parents
can communicate that responsibility to
their kids incredible the only thing if
we were sitting down having nachos and a
drink I would say
I think there's a moment in time when
it's very important to invite in a
select group of people that you do allow
to pour into you that you do allow to
um
positively and I don't say negatively
impact you but hold you accountable yeah
and I think we have a culture that says
you are all that you need and I'll tell
you behind closed doors the psychiatrist
and the psychologist and the researchers
are starting to say
the self can't hold the self was not
designed to hold up the universe and we
thought self-actualization we thought if
we could just get full ownership it was
just all you and it's all you ever need
then we'd be okay what we're realizing
is we can't do Life by ourselves and
that's that's not me just doing
Instagram lines that is neuroscience
right and so I do think it's important
um I think I've got six maybe seven now
people and they know who they are that
I've said you've got permission to call
me out and I'm gonna lean on you to help
fill me up I need to hold my arms up in
the desert when I when I got nothing
left right I think it's important to
have those people in your life I think
that's true I I do like the Highlight on
uh your choices are your choice right
like like you said in today's world
where there's so much
entitlement and this is the reason my
life is bad it's the government it's
inflation it's because I never went to
college it's because I did go to college
it's because my parents like you can
point the finger in so many directions
but at the end of the day this is just
me I'm telling y'all what I learned
whatever it is I'm complaining about
whatever it is that I'm mad about there
is something that I can do
to change it and to make it better I
could say well my marriage would be
better if my husband was more like this
or my job would be better if my boss was
more like this right but there's always
something that you can do just you not
waiting on them air quotes around them
there's always something you can do to
make that better and I did take that
away from that like bro me is always a
problem I can solve if I'm unhappy I
need to change something if I don't like
my life I need to change something if I
don't like my marriage my job whatever
it is there is something that you can do
and I bet you this because I've lived it
I bet you when you start moving you're
going to be surprised at the domino
effect it has on other people right
positively and negative positively and
some people like you stuck where you are
sure but it's gonna have that effect
that it's gonna be like oh you're like
that okay I need to move you out I need
to move you out and so I do I do like
that um part of it but I agree John the
community thing is huge like when I got
here okay so we just moved from 4 to
Tennessee I immediately got with my
counselor and I was like how much time
do I have to get a community around me
before I start to crack right and she
was like yeah she was like you need to
meet people I was like because I I came
from such a strong
group of folks that can speak into my
life and they still can over the
telephone but you it's different yeah
it's different so I do think that you
need that that piece of people going hey
you're not like that like what are you
doing right you know so I tell
um privately I've told the story this
first time I'm telling it publicly I
think but
um
it was about a year into this job and I
posted some somebody wrote something
awful and I screenshot it and just had
like an arrow and I commented back and
um just really put them on blast and I'm
not gonna lie it was real funny it was
real funny and one of my closest friends
called me and he he was laughing as I
answered the phone and I was like what's
up he goes dude I just saw your post
he's dying laughing I was like I was
awesome and he goes take it down oh I
said what do you mean take it down it's
hilarious oh it's super funny and then
he said that's not you yeah and that's
not how you want to represent yourself
take it down and here's the deal I was
mad and I trusted him and so I took it
down not because I was I'm coloring to
the man it's crazy I've given that man
permission to speak into my life and he
saw a side of me that said that's not
the guy I know yeah and if you go down
this road you're gonna end up way over
here I'm just gonna call you now what a
gift but that says a lot about you as a
person because in the world we are today
the people get offended so easily you
you do one thing and somebody holds you
accountable and suddenly it's like this
whole thing of you're not letting me
live in my truth and you're not letting
me you know do this thing and I'm like
if you're a person if you become
um so high and mighty and I'm gonna call
it an ego because that's what it is that
no one can speak to you no one can say
hey and I don't mean just some dude off
the streets I'm talking about the people
in your life can't come up to you and
say hey you're wrong and you're not
willing to enter into conflict with
anyone and come out on the other side of
it that that's a problem
you will crash I don't have those people
like my buddy my buddy Porsha
she knows
if I'm acting up she's the one that
needs to call me up and be like no no
you're you're not being yourself right
now like that's not who you are that's
not the way you act I can call her and
tell her hey you know this dude is
acting like this and she'll be like well
like you you could have here was your
part in it and that's the type of
relationship we'd have and if you don't
have that with people whether it be your
spouse you know your homie whatever it
is dude you're setting yourself up to
fail because you need that cup that
you're looking at but you need to let
somebody else look at the cup too that's
right if you're holding your cup over
here to the side like off in the corner
where nobody else can see it good luck
to you and if you're a mess like me you
need several people looking at that cup
making sure John let me see your cup
your head screwed on straight man it's a
dark dark side cup all right let's run
out to Zack and toms do we have time to
take a call here yeah we got time we
gotta go out to uh Zach and Tom's River
Zach we're right up against the clock so
get right to your question brother
hi thank you for taking my call right up
against the clock so get right to the
question
all right so my wife and I are
aggressively paying off student loan
debt and card debt um we're paying off
about 80 000 this year and that's going
to be the end of our day except way to
go that's great
thank you um we both agree our house is
too small right now to continue growing
our family so we want to build a custom
home on an architecture if you want me
to design it
um you know our house right now is too
small for anything abundant water
um there's just no yard and we literally
just run her up and down the hallway
yeah um but you don't want to sell our
house um but my wife doesn't want to
wait two years to save her down payment
to build the house and she brought the
idea of the home equity loan that gets
down payment no no no no no no no no no
no
the answer is no you are right sorry
wifey wifey is wrong on this one you're
right we are not going into home equity
line of credit to do anything I don't
care if she wants to expand the house
with the home equity line of credit I
don't care what she planned on doing
with this home equity line of credit the
answer is going to be no the best way to
buy a home is to do it the right way
which is either to sell the house that
you have after you've paid off the debt
and take whatever Equity you have and
roll it into the next home where the
payment is no more than 25 of your
income and that is on a 15-year fixed
conventional loan that's the only way
we're doing this thing no HELOC no and
listen I promise you when your kid is
five they'd much rather a stress-free
home with no debt than a strapped mom
and dad in a postage stamp size yard
okay John don't do it don't do it this
is the Ramsey Show we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
today's scripture of the day is Proverbs
12 11. those who work their land will
have abundant food but those whose Chase
fantasies have no sense
Jackie Robinson says life is not a
spectator sport if you're gonna spend
your whole life in the grandstand just
watching what goes on in my opinion
you're wasting your life full Jackie
boom bringing it all right let's go out
to Jordan in the NYC what's up Jordan
how you doing John pleasure thanks for
taking my call you got it what's up so
uh my wife um she started orientation
for her new job she's a nurse so we
needed somebody to watch our
three-year-old while I work on um
between hours and uh we had her
mother-in-law come by and it's been
about six weeks now she's finished her
orientation and my wife wants her to
stay for a little bit longer but in the
last six or eight weeks our bills have
gone through the roof oh she gots to go
dude hey Jordan best of luck to you my
friend
so I'm at a Crossroads here because you
know
you know now my wife is saying that you
know that her job wanted to work days
for a few weeks to get adjusted to it
and you know she's off by three o'clock
it doesn't take much time out of my day
I'm pretty much home three out of the
four days out the week I go to the
office two days a week and you know I
don't know how to tell her hey your mom
has to go because I was you know hey
Jordan what are these bills
um well my electricity bill has gone
from 300 which it averages to 670. oh
gosh how so she's cold she's turning the
heat up she's almost she's there all day
[Music]
oh man she's turning the heat up she's
eating all the lunch meat
what else
and and the heating bill too so I have
propane Heats on electricity
dude oh man okay can we have real talk
for one second
yes all right so we there is a financial
aspect to this okay no question we're
trying to get out of that I know I know
but hold up when you were dating your
wife
and you fell head over Jordan heels for
her
money didn't matter
you figured it out you had a test coming
up in college I don't care I'm gonna go
see her a Show's coming to town she
don't want to go am I going
you figure it out
and now you got mother-in-law there
staying with the family and then these
bills come in bills are real that that
is hundreds of dollars that were not on
the tab just a couple weeks ago and here
they are that's real and
there's something underneath it that's
getting into you what is it
well for her being here for six weeks I
don't think much has changed you know my
wife has said you know we'll get to go
out we'll uh get to do things because
there's somebody to watch the baby all
the time and none of those things have
happened all right now we're getting to
it do you and your mother-in-law get
along
I I see there you know there's no uh you
know she gets in the way let's just put
it like hey she's probably not listening
so you can tell us the truth did she get
in the way like just because it's your
house you want to walk around in your
underwear if you want to because it's my
house or is she getting away like she's
just taking things upon herself like you
know the UPS guy comes um I run a small
business we'll get mail come and
packages and there's multiple packages
that I can't find because she said she
puts them somewhere and it's not there
and the other day I found two of them
outside in boxes oh by the recycle yikes
okay okay all right so Jordan here's
here's where you got to go okay
I don't envy you
because at the end of the day you do
have somebody that in their heart and
mind came into hell right and your wife
probably feels a sense of both duty to
mom to give her a purpose and just a
comforting sense that there's somebody
else there watching the kid all that
stuff
I think if you haven't before it's gonna
be the first time you've ever sat down
and not use the word she and them and
y'all but you sit down with your wife in
a private conversation and say me
I'm struggling I feel like I've lost my
house the house that you and I share
that you had higher building
um our bills have doubled if not more so
I got packages disappearing I love and
honor the fact that your mom packed up
and came out here and
I really am I'm feeling less and less
safe in my own house not in a someone's
going to get me kind of way but like I'm
losing my own home and I don't want to
have another parent in this house and so
give your wife an opportunity to speak
back and because it may be an issue of
boundaries it may be an issue of hey if
there's a package that comes to this
house don't touch it I'll pick it up or
put it right here in this area or
something like that but can he also say
we agreed that this was going to be for
absolutely six months or what what did
you say six weeks or six months six six
weeks okay and now how long has it been
it's been we're eight weeks now okay so
can he say hey we agree this was going
to be six weeks and I I was really great
with that agreement but I don't I don't
know how I don't feel good about eight
weeks or longer yes but here's my
concern Jordan
that you've got other issues going on in
your marriage
and I don't want it all coming out of
mother-in-law or wife you seem like a
straightforward kind of guy like myself
and sometimes we can bust in the room
and be like you said that this was only
gonna be like this and now look at this
what are you gonna do like that's look
Jordan that's how we are I'ma just put
myself in there that's that's happened
that's how we are we got we gotta hold
back Jordan we gotta we gotta find our
inner John deloney speak to be heard not
so you have uh not be not just to have
said something okay speak to me she sees
she also sees that you know because
she's made comments here and there like
the things that she thought her mother
would be doing to make her life easier
isn't happening yeah and maybe you're
maybe your wife desperately wants you to
step up and be the bad guy here and tell
your wife I'm happy to be the bad guy
here oh I'm happy wait wait no I don't
okay John we rarely disagree but I don't
I don't agree well I'm saying this when
I say bad guy I I'm willing to say hey
my my oh yeah you can't you can't tell
me yeah you're right you're right you're
right you can't come that's on me I'm
wrong I'm wrong I don't know that you're
wrong I'm just saying I wouldn't try it
good call out
yeah Jordan y'all need to be United on
it and at this point
um your wife's gonna have to
be a grown-up too and sit down and say
hey here's in two weeks we need we're
ready to transition and get our house
back we're so grateful for you here's a
really fancy dinner here's a night out
on the town here we're taking you a
Broadway play whatever we want to do
we're gonna do something really nice but
it's time yeah is that gonna go over
well with your wife wrap it in a thank
you yep I she used she for the most part
she follows my lead but you know it's
her mother and she's the youngest of
eight yeah
where's where does Mom go after this
back to Boston
she has a place or she's going to
another sibling
she has a place but she's usually she
she lives in Florida but she spends most
of her time with her kids in Boston and
and it's like her sister lives 10
minutes down the street she doesn't she
doesn't want to go and see her sister
okay well that's a her issue not you
guys I'd say out of that stuff but Hey
listen if if you and your wife had plans
like hey when you get to this nursing
job we're gonna be able to go out we're
gonna have extra money all that and
that's not happening don't roll all that
stress into this conversation
because it can be real easy that all of
a sudden this conversation turns into uh
and you said this and this never happens
and now your mom's here and now we're at
War and nobody's gonna win
let this be about hey want to get our
house back we said six weeks it's been
eight weeks let's count at ten weeks
this is done
um let's sit down together and have this
conversation I was wrong Jay was right
don't don't divide it up
um we're gonna do this one together and
then let's have a different conversation
now that she's settling into her new job
now that you're settled in now that you
got your house back what is it going to
look like to have a date night once a
week that's why we work so hard I don't
want to I don't want to have a one night
one night a month with you one night a
week with you I went two nights a week
with you what is it going to look like
to find Child Care what's it going to
look like to do all these things to
create a life that is worth living man
yeah so in and so good for you Jordan
thanks for thanks for trusting us
um you do have to have a hard
conversation but again remember make the
conversation especially initially about
you what you're struggling with what
you're upset with what's hurting you
um not don't come in guns ablazing
because your wife's gonna have one
option that's to defend herself and now
you got world war three and there's no
sense in that I don't envy him but I
think if he wraps it up like you said
wrap the Mother-in-law up in a thank you
thank you for all of this here's a meal
we're so appreciative then you bring the
wife over here and wrap that up in a
nice date and it's like hey I've missed
you like any time look if anytime your
husband or spouse comes at you with the
I miss you I want to be with you I don't
get to spend enough time with you if
you're not melting down I don't know
what's happening to you I don't know
what's happening go go melter like
butter like a hot knife through butter
man we have very different spouses all
right this is the Ramsey Show thanks to
the guys in the booth Kelly was there
and she took off as usual hey thank you
America for sticking with us thank you
Jade and listen pay off your debts be
kind to one another we'll see you soon
right here on the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button will help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]